autre rassemblement à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis pour dénoncer cette
fois le projet d'implantation du grand
hôpital nord ce nouveau campus on doit
comporter 900 lits il verra le jour en
2028 et doit être implantée sur le site
de l'ancienne usine psa et selon le
collectif pas ça à la va comme ça ce
centre hospitalier va entraîner la
fermeture des hôpitaux bichat dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris et
beaujon à clichy ainsi que la perte de
305 lee
c'est une action importante parce que
c'est une action qui rejoignit qui
réunit les soignants les usagers de
l'hôpital public et les citoyens qui
protestent contre ce projet d'hôpital
grand paris nord qui prévoit de fermer
deux énormes hôpitaux qui sont l'hôpital
bichat et cocktails beaujon pour en
faire un seul à saint-ouen le fait de
faire un nouvel hôpital en soit c'est
plutôt très bien
le problème c'est qu'on prévoit de
fermer déjà deux grosses structures et
de fermer 300 lits en fait dans le
problème plus de 300 lits ce qui
correspond à 29 % de l'offre de soins de
l'hôpital de deux lits d'hôpitaux
stagnation complète dans ce nouvel
hôpital
alors aujourd'hui à faire à une action
symbolique puisqu'il ya l'hôpital
beaujon et bichat qui sont menacés de
fermer pour la presse une super
structure qui va avoir clé est
construite juste derrière nous et en
fait cette fermeture va entraîner la
suppression de 3 105 lits ça veut dire 3
105 places d'hospitalisation en moins
pour des patients pour vous pour nous
nos familles et dans un secteur qui est
très touchée et par la pandémie est dans
un secteur qui est très dansant niveau
de pau